I know you're a fan of RuPaul's Drag you
like the biggest sin but I would say
that's good fan uh who are you living
for this scene say okay did such a
conversation get first of all Brooklyn
Heights like we're gonna I just your
class fantastic brilliant what I love
about Brooklyn and I have to say this is
you know she gets told maybe her
personality isn't the loudest but I
don't feel like she needs to be loud
know her personality comes out on the
run and even if she's beautiful her
pieces are so well thought every luck
she's brilliant um who else
I love still cute heard you talked with
Gigi and I and I understand however she
grew up me on this at this to friends of
mine I would like a look at this video
silky look at her dance I'm like okie is
an incredible perform is how beautiful -
she's beautiful she's a great performer
in like a million I just can't get
behind somebody who's always screaming
and just always yelling and fighting
with Pete right that's not my vibe at
all like I'm a lover I'm not a fighter
another - you know what I mean sure but
like it's such a pressurized inner side
I mean we'll see what happens
[Music]
what does that have to do don't go on
topic I really I love easy but I like I
think I have a more of a crush on boy
Aviva anything else well start us up
that up okay if I go like all right do
you that makes me happy um then a you
know Vangie always seems so proud of
vengence she's like she's just perfect
on her own and vegies her own cow she's
own character she has her own empire and
I'm not gonna lie no tea no shade no
pink lemonade I'm kind of over Vangie
same looks every single week she was so
traumatized by the first episode of last
season that like now she all she wears
is a body suit she's like I'm just gonna
give you that to it forever
[Music]
you